oh man watchdogs I was really looking
forward to playing on my playstation 4
footing what it was supposed to go back
I don't know seems kind of Assassin's
Creed II GT a familiar read to me and at
delay
hmm I don't know is it good sign or bad
tine or really bad time very few games
get worse with extra development time I
have concerns because sometimes when
games get so overly hyped they just
can't live up to the expectations rise
son of Rome doctor who's the best game
is the best game people like Dark Souls
2 it's like you might as well just pry
your own fingernails off I don't get it
Dark Souls 2 i will definitely attempt
to play again until I stop attempting it
because of death in the game not not in
I have children and I don't have hours
to go run off and get killed and then
after you take hours to go back and get
my corpse I don't imagine I'll get
annoyed through it I don't imagine I'll
be any good at it but I'm certainly
intending to try I didn't like missed
very much it seems kind of misty but
it's colorful and sure why not I need
something to play on my playstation does
anyone know what the witness is about
really like they don't actually know
what's going on in the witness if
there's a part in the witness where you
get to ride around in the Tesla car with
Jonathan Blow that would be awesome I
don't give a [ __ ] about the witness I
have watched many CSI episodes which
have a witness what I like about second
son is that actually doesn't really look
like an infamous game to me when you pop
in and out of smoke form when you go
from shooting to do to turn on dime to
jump onto a building like all of the
moment-to-moment beat to beat like
momentum the dialogue is so good
sometimes like what you think I like
arresting my brother all time the guys
like well maybe you shouldn't arrest
your brother all the time I think I was
the only one laughing
it's definitely got me excited and like
that kind of next-gen mean the
excitement of like this game might look
really good and be really good yeah yeah
so the division is probably my most
anticipated game of 2014 that I don't
expect to come out in 2014 the division
it's not even in town so I feel like
that should be most anticipated 2015 or
something the division is a game that
I'm convinced will never actually come
out I just want like a sort of a
modern-day Fallout that has better
shooting and more collaboration in a
very abstract way I'm excited about the
division even though I don't really know
what that game is about as one of the
lucky few people who got to play
titanfall this year at an event I would
have to say my excitement for that game
is somewhere along the lines of it I am
just convinced already that I'm going to
spend hundreds of hours playing that
this year I think titanfall is probably
my most anticipated game of 2014 that I
actually think is going to come out on
in 2014 I know a lot of people have
played it and they're absolutely in love
with it and they can't stop talking
about it
Danny O'Dwyer so one of the coolest
conversations we frequently have in the
office is which is the best Metal Gear
Solid how long came out just out of five
because I want to know what the goddamn
has going on in Hideo Kojima's minds
I don't dear Solid five not that excited
about it we'll all these new people
which version of snake is this a big
boss why is there monkey with a can of
coke why is there a sniper who's wearing
no clothes I think it tremendous world I
think it's really interesting unique to
explore and then doing that with my
friends makes it all the better I'm kind
of not too hot on destiny so into Bungie
and I am so so excited for destiny
destiny might be my most anticipated
game of 2014
geralt of rivia is back and it's like an
open world kind of oh man I definitely
excited for The Witcher 3 I'm probably
going to get two which is three because
I just upgraded my PC and I want to see
how sick all them graphics look the
richest three is one of those games
where I don't need to see any more of it
I don't need to watch a trailer I don't
need to read a single bit of coverage I
know that that game is gonna be awesome
and I it's I am in complete media
blackout mode for that I you don't need
to show me anymore I'm sold
who owns our Wii U who doesn't like
mario kart mario kart 8 is a new mario
kart game well am i supposed to say
anything else
Nintendo I want to have a serious
conversation with you and that is a
conversation about the blue shell I
think we both know what I'm talking
about here you know what to do with that
blue shell make the right decision
you